ich habe ja geschrieben wie kann man für
so einen dummen youtuber eine fanseite
machen omg dann hat fanpages geschrieben
lernen erst mal deutsch beziehungsweise
englisch dann habe ich geschrieben
lernen doch erstmal selber französischer
erst mal leute was gehabt und jetzt
bekommen bei einem neuen video ja leute
dürfen natürlich euch wie gut wir haben
heute samstag und ich komme gerade von
der uni weil ich habe einfach eine
klausur geschrieben das war auch kein
nachschreibetermin uhr so das ist für
uns völlig normal beschreiben einfach
manchmal samstags klausuren dann aber
auch nicht so um acht uhr morgens
sondern einfach um 11.30 und das bei 29
grad im schatten kann man sich
vorstellen wie scheiße das ist aber ich
bin während der klausur auf eine echt
coole idee gekommen und zwar habe ich
letztens zur videos gesehen da haben
halt leute so undercover mit fanpages
geschrieben oder halt seiten die von
zuschauern gemacht wurden für mich also
so hallt der schon fanpages und ich habe
mir gedacht eigentlich voll cool aber
das habe jetzt schon relativ viele
gemacht also braucht es nicht auch
machen aber ich bin auf die idee
gekommen
wir machen das nicht so standardmäßig
jona lakers voll cool und so was für das
tool an dem ich finde das cool an ihm
und so rainer nein wir machen das anders
und zwar habe ich eine hater page
erstellt die nennt sich hier anti alex
wie aber schon ein foto hochgeladen
ja also wie kann man denn nur mögen und
habe auch schon ein paar fanpages
gefolgt so den aktivsten die ich selber
kenne und folgen des jetzt wir machen
das jetzt einfach so ich schreib dir
natürlich und gebt euch mal so updates
und ich schieße voll gegen mich selber
so alex ist voll scheiße wie kann man
ihn nur mögen das ganze heute über den
tag verteilen weil ich nicht denke dass
die schnelle antworten werden manche
sicherlich schon die anderen nicht erst
auf jeden fall machen doch noch um dafür
die coole idee und ich gehe jetzt
erstmal burger ist das hat mir wirklich
verdient später also ich bin jetzt
wieder da ich habe mir jetzt hier so
eine kleine ecke eingerichtet wir haben
ja einmal dieses wunderschöne licht und
meine kamera das jetzt hier so die
nächsten keine ahnung
zehn stunden so stehen bleiben wird denn
ich habe es ja gerade schon angesprochen
vermutlich antwortet nicht jeder sofort
ich mache einfach mal kurz die
bildschirmaufnahme
starten ich habe jetzt gerade mal die
bildschirmaufnahme gestartet und wir
sind in meinem profil ich habe euch das
ja gerade schon gezeigt das ganze nennt
sich anti alex wie ein foto haben wir
schon habe ich gestern schon gepostet
hat nur likes ist habe ich mit snapshot
bearbeitet genial aber darum geht es ja
gar nicht es geht einfach nur darum mit
halt so fanpage ist von mir ja so einen
kleinen konflikt aufzubauen und ich bin
wirklich gespannt was da kommen wird ich
habe es jetzt diesen sechs fanseiten
gefolgt alex wie fanbox alex liess weil
wörtlich sandwich alex wie alex wie
fällen absolut das andere nicht
ich habe mir auch gefolgt ein voller
mehr und so lege jetzt einfach mal hier
ja auf die seite wir haben jetzt hier
fanpage alex wie wird sagen wir fangen
wir ganz locker an mit so einem
übergeben smiley
es sieht ganz gut aus wir bei der
nächsten seite habe dieses bild grausam
da kommen wir noch gleich mal zwei
übergeben smileys hin und noch ein
saurer smiley und meinetwegen noch mal
übergeben smiley und jetzt nehmen wir
einfach mal hier
dieser fan page alex wiesler schreibe
ich jetzt einfach mal wie kann man den
nur toll finden unverständlich hashtag
dumm hashtag ich bin cool mit smiley und
abschicken
so durch habe gerade gesehen wie die
seite alex wie fireworks hat mich sogar
schon zurück abonniert keine ahnung
warum aber danke ihr könnt natürlich
auch gerne den fanpages schauen wir kurz
die story ist das auch kommt das gibt
auch noch hier und fanpage alex wichtig
auch noch eine nachricht wie kann man
für so einen dummen youtuber eine
fanseite machen umgeht man muss es ja
auch immer möglichst real halten und
alle guten dinge sind drei was kann man
jetzt ausschreiben alex wie es der
schlechteste youtuber den es gibt und je
geben wird und je gegeben hat herrscht
der cajun country hashtag alex wie
senden so bis jetzt hat sich noch keiner
zurückgemeldet auch auf meinen kommentar
wurde noch nicht geantwortet deswegen
heißt es jetzt einfach ein bisschen
abwarten
ich will jetzt noch ein bisschen
rausgehen und wir sehen uns dann
gleich wieder als wir haben jetzt 1854
wahrscheinlich so im zwei drei stunden
ist dann so leute ich bin jetzt wieder
da wundert euch nicht über das hier ich
musste mich ein bisschen ein geben
bekannt dass wir wahrscheinlich wenn es
irgendwo brennt wir schauen jetzt
einfach mal nach ob ich hier die eine
andere nachricht bekommen hab ja und
zwar von alex wie fanbox lerne zuerst
rechtschreibung bevor du so etwas
schreibt einfach nur lächerlich und wir
haben einfach mal weiter rauf ich
schreibe jetzt mal was richtig gemein
ist und zwar hab mein gott aber dafür
habe ich nicht eine fanpage so wie du
sondern eine hayta page so jetzt hab ich
es ihr gegeben hashtag hater und auch
hier würden smiley okay leider muss ich
sagen fanpage alex wird nicht
geantwortet alexis boeuf auch nicht und
deswegen kopieren wir jetzt mal das
ganze hier oder es gibt jedoch mehrere
pages und wir schicken einfach mal den
gleichen text an so viele wie möglich
was sie aber auch komisch finde diese
hält kommentare von mir wurden einfach
komplett ignoriert da ja ich gebe
natürlich nicht auf ich gehe es immer
schlafen mal gucken wie es morgen
aussieht ich schicke jetzt noch ein paar
fanpages sind extra und dann stehen die
morgen auf der richtig böse nachricht
also bis morgen so leute herzlich
willkommen zur neuen location des videos
ja ich bin jetzt hier in meinem zimmer
ist es auch schon ein tag vergangen also
eigentlich wollte ich das gestern
aufnehmen allerdings ist was dazwischen
gekommen und zwar konnte ich noch diese
kommunikation aufbauen ich habe
geschrieben wie kann man für so einen
dummen youtuber eine fanseite machen
geht dann hat fanpages geschrieben
lernen erst mal deutsch beziehungsweise
englisch dann hab ich geschrieben lernen
doch erstmal selber französischer erst
mal ich habe aber noch ganz viele andere
seiten angeschrieben und habe mich
irgendwann gewundert warum gar nichts
mehr kam und irgendwie konnte ich auch
gar nicht mehr hier meinen feed neuladen
ich dachte das leaking wie administrator
am kleinen bug oder so hat man ja
manchmal auf einem anderen account also
alex wie account geht's allerdings und
wenn man jetzt hier den account wechselt
oder wenn man das jetzt hier mal sieht
da ist halt kein profilbild mehr und ich
kann ja auch nix licon oder so und mein
profil hier ist halt einfach weg geld
weg
alles weg ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus
das konto gesperrt weil es dann
wahrscheinlich
seiten gemeldet haben oder so muss ich
erst mal sagen mega cool weil wenn das
halt das kommt natürlich vor dass sich
irgendwer wirklich so eine page erstellt
und dann die leute antreibt und mich zum
teil auch aber das zeigt dass wenn viele
leute die person melden dass das konto
dann halt wirklich gesperrt wird du
jetzt habe ich nur ein kleines problem
weil ich zwar jetzt schon ein video habe
aber nicht wirklich mit viel inhalt also
so die heftigsten jets waren da jetzt
nicht dabei aber ich kann ja nichts
machen war anscheinend es war eine coole
idee die aber nicht so leicht umzusetzen
ist deswegen beantworte ich jetzt noch
ein paar fragen ja also ich hoffe wir
nehmen wir das jetzt nicht übel dass ich
macht haben sind auch mal gut classic
micro hat wie oft hast du sex kann ich
natürlich ganz klar beantworten genau
1326 mal
ich mache so eine strichliste und macht
dann immer so und wenn er wieder fünf
voll sind dann kommt so ein querstrich
wie früher in der schule war natürlich
nur ein spaß hast du noch deine
weisheitszähnen nein habe ich nicht die
sind zum glück noch drin was ach so habe
ich einen fehler gemacht im letzten
fragen an gott video ich habe meine
weisheitszähne macht also die sind noch
drin lässt hat es hier allerdings mal
kurz weg ist aber wieder weg deswegen
habe ich dir auch immer so jeanette
fragt hast du fake account um deine
eigenen sachen zu liken kommentiert oder
eltern unbekannt zu schreiben
warte mal der kommentar fast echt gut
aber eigentlich ja umgedreht also ich
habe ja keinen account um helfern
unbekannt zu schreiben sondern ich bin
ein hater um fanpages unbekannt zu
schreiben oder so aber nein an sich habe
ich natürlich keine anderen account ich
habe auch eine instagram voller
klamotten marke seite aber das war es
dann auch früher hatte ich bestimmt
fünfzehn youtube account und hatte auf
meine videos aber auch nur 30 like sind
um diese 30 likes und 15 discs halt
nicht ganz so schlimm aussehen zu lassen
habe ich dann selber noch ein bisschen
hoch gelegt aber das brauche ich ja
heutzutage zum glück nicht mehr machen
hashtag freaks also jetzt mit hashtags
fragen in die kommentare damit ich immer
sofort weiß was ist eine frage und was
ist nun kommentar ihr könnt hier
darunter auch gerne fragen stellen ist
es schlimm wenn ich einen pulli von jack
& jones für 30 euro habe habe davon zwei
von meiner mutter gekriegt und t shirts
habe ich von einem nachbarn geschenkt
gekriegt und nochmal zwei pullis von
meinem nachbar
nein ist nicht schlimm sollte ihnen
jetzt darauf antworten also ich finde
jeder sollte tragen was er will und das
tragen was sehr schön findet viele sagen
mir auch alex was hast du heute schon
wieder an das passt da überhaupt nichts
zusammen
solange ich selber das schön finde bist
du alles cool und was du jetzt genau
hier mit sagen will weiß ich nicht aber
jack & jones police sind doch schön
also ist es nicht schlimm und die laura
fragt hashtag felix ich finde den
hashtag echt gut
warum bin ich da nicht drauf gekommen
was sagst du dazu dass mein freund mir
zwischen die beine tritt ps kein fake ps
ich bin ein mädchen und bin
kannst du mich bitte grüßen genug
internet für heute schluss neo mehr zu
sein diese fast schon mit elfen freund
und zweitens ist es natürlich nicht gut
wenn er dir zwischen die beide tritt ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob du schon weißt was
das auslösen kann wer dir zwischen die
beine tritt hauptsache du machst ist
nicht auch bei ihm weil das tut noch
mehr anleger habe ich am ganzen für ich
sagen ich hoffe das video hat euch ein
bisschen unterhalten auch wenn es sehr
schade war dass mein held account nicht
aufgegangen ist oder so wie es geplant
hatte
lasst mir gerne daumen nach oben da und
wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder ich muss vielleicht meinen koffer
packen weil ich zu meinen eltern in den
urlaub fliege ich habe jetzt meine
letzte klausur geschrieben gestern und
in köln ist das wetter heute irgendwie
ziemlich kalt und es regnet weil ich die
hälfte vom video schon geschnitten habe
nicht dass ihr euch wundert ich habe am
anfang gesagt ja heute ist's ja samstag
und wir haben ja jetzt heute schon
dienstag als ich hab das video samstag
angefangen heute am dienstag die letzten
partner von aufgenommen und genau sechs
deutsche tänze gehabt wir sehen uns
morgen wieder rein